en este vídeo voy a utilizar la
Inteligencia artificial para hacer
apuestas deportivas con el objetivo de
ganar dinero lo que hemos hecho ha sido
crear un Bot que nos va a decir En qué
equipo tenemos que apostar para así
tener la mayor probabilidad de acabar
ganando dinero y este Bot va a tener en
cuenta dos cosas lo primero son los
partidos anteriores de esos equipos de
fútbol y lo segundo es la cuota
básicamente es el multiplicador y es la
cifra por la cual se va a multiplicar
nuestro dinero Si acabamos acertando La
Apuesta Bueno chicos ya ha pasado una
semana Estamos a martes y hecho Ni más
ni menos que 9 apuestas de estas nueve
apuestas he ganado tres y os voy a
enseñar Cuáles han sido los resultados
la primera Que gané fue esta y esto
quiere decir que nos han multiplicado
los 100 euros por 1.93 y hemos
conseguido ganar 193 euros la siguiente
que hemos ganado ha sido esta que
también apostamos 100 euros y la cuota
puede 1.74 Así que ganamos 177 euros y
la última que ganamos que es la cuota
más alta apostamos también 100 euros y
la cuota fueron 2.47 Así que conseguimos
ganar 247 euros empezamos a hacer las
apuestas hace una semana con mil euros y
a día de hoy tenemos
726,63 euros Así que hemos acabado
perdiendo